can you tell me how much money was given
to drag queen's Story Hour
I'm sorry could you repeat that drag
queen Story Time where where men dress
up as women and read confusing books to
Children first I thought you said dry
clean so I'm sorry uh no I don't know
the answer to either one of those two oh
we need to look into this and I urge you
to do that they Bradbury Sullivan LGBT
community center in Pennsylvania
received sixteen thousand dollars for
drag queen story time uh from from
coveted cash
um I think this is an issue that needs
to be looked into a lot of this money
went to things that should have never
gone to and I thank you so much and I
yield back the remainder of my time if
only she would permanently yield back
the remainder of her time I think
America would be better off
look if an lgbtq Community Center
received covid funds it's not
specifically earmarked for drag queen
Story Hour